[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
CASEY RODRIGUEZ: So
we ended last time
with these elementary
properties that you
know about the absolute value.
So let me prove one more theorem
about the absolute value, which
maybe you didn't
cover in calculus.
But it's of
fundamental importance
in real analysis, which is
the triangle inequality, which
states that for all xy in R,
the absolute value of x plus y
is less than or equal to
the absolute value of x
plus the absolute value of y.
So why is it called the
triangle inequality?
Well, let me-- instead of
x and y being real numbers,
let's think of these as vectors.
So there's x.
Let's say y.
And then vector x
plus y is this side.
Then what this is stating
is that the length
of one of these sides
of this triangle
is less than or equal
to the sum of the two
sides, the sum of the lengths
of the other two sides
of the triangle.
So that's why it's called
the triangle inequality.
OK, so the proof is
not very difficult,
although this
inequality is probably
one of the three most
useful things you'll
learn in this class if you go
on to study more analysis--
the other one being--
OK, so I'm coming--
this is knowledge from PDE.
So I guess I'm viewing it
through that lens of what
I find useful in PDEs.
But triangle inequality,
integration by parts,
change of variables, those
three power the analysis machine
that I'm most familiar with.
So how to prove the
triangle inequality--
if x and y is an R, then
clearly, by property number 6,
the x is less than or
equal to the absolute value
of x and y is less than or equal
to the absolute value of y.
So their sum is less than or
equal to the absolute value
of x plus y.
And not only that, I can
replace x by minus x and I
get minus x plus
minus y, this is
less than or equal to the
absolute value of minus x
plus the absolute
value of minus y.
But this is just absolute
value of x plus y.
And both of these
therefore imply--
so if I just take this and
multiply through by minus 1,
this inequality,
which, by number 5
in the properties that we
proved, for the absolute value
implies that the absolute
value of x plus y is less than
or equal to the
absolute value of x
plus the absolute value of y.
So let me just make a remark
about the reverse triangle
Inequality, which will make an
appearance in your assignment.
And so this involves the
absolute value of x minus y
and the absolute value
of the difference
in the absolute values.
Why is it reverse?
Because the inequality reverses.
The absolute value of x minus
the absolute value and y,
take the absolute value.
This is less than or equal
to the absolute value
of x minus y.
And you'll prove this
in the assignment.
So these two-- so this follows
from the triangle inequality.
But these two inequalities
get used quite a bit.
And we'll use them quite a
bit throughout the course.
All right, so let me take
a minute to reconnect R
with what you know and love
from calculus, namely decimals.
And we're going to
use this fact about R
to answer a natural
question that maybe you're
asking yourself, which
is the following.
So let me raise
this as a question.
So this first part
is not the question.
We've already addressed this in
the first assignment, the fact
that the rationals is countable.
In fact, you did it for
the positive rationals.
But if the positive
rationals are countable,
you can then prove that all
rationals are countable.
And a natural question--
is R countable?
Or is the set of real
numbers countable?
So in the end--
I'm not going to leave
you in suspense--
the answer is no.
And we're going to prove this.
But let me just make a few
remarks about what this says.
So it's the following.
So if Q-- so this is
not a proof of this.
I'm just going to make a
remark based on this answer.
So since R is uncountable
and Q is countable,
this implies that R takeaway Q,
the set of irrational numbers,
is, in fact, uncountable.
Why?
So I'm just going to say
in words why this is true.
So suppose otherwise that
both the rational numbers
and the irrationals
are countable.
Then you can map in
a bijective fashion
the rationals to the natural
numbers and the irrationals
also to the natural numbers.
But then you can map those
natural numbers to 0, minus 1,
minus 2, minus 3, and so on.
So then you find that
there is a bijection
from Q to the natural
numbers and the irrationals
to the integers less
than or equal to 0.
And therefore, there's bijection
from R to the integers.
But the integers are countable,
which would contradict the fact
that R is uncountable.
Therefore, the set of
irrationals is uncountable.
So in short, if you
didn't follow that,
the set of irrationals
is uncountable
because otherwise this would
force R to be countable.
Now, I haven't proved yet
that R is uncountable.
We'll do that in just a minute.
And we'll use a theorem about
decimal expansions for--
or decimal representations
of real numbers.
So now, connecting
rationals and irrationals
to what you've seen
since you were small,
so to decimals, we simply--
we typically-- we think
of rational numbers
as in terms of decimal
representations.
What does that mean?
That means we take--
if x is in Q, then we'll write x
as some number times some digit
times 10 to the k plus 10
to the k minus 1 plus d0.
And then we go to the
tenths spot, so d to the--
d minus 1 10 to
the minus 1 plus--
so this is discussion.
I'm not stating any
theorems right now,
until we get down to maybe
some last decimal spot.
And with these digits,
a subset of 0, 1, 9.
So all I'm saying is typically
we think of x as this way.
And then we write x as dk, dk
minus 1, d minus 1, d minus 2,
and so on.
I'm using this notation
because I'm going to be--
this is the notation I
need to state the theorem
about the real numbers.
But it's quite silly that
I'm about to write this down
in this setting.
Welcome to MIT.
So for example, 1
times 10 plus 1 times
10 to the 0 plus 1
times 10 to the minus 1.
This is supposed to represent
the number 11.1, which
is the rational number.
It's quite funny that I had to
think about that for a minute
to go from the decimal expansion
to the rational numbers.
But don't give me
too hard of a time.
In a lot of at least
pure math, we typically
write things in
rational numbers.
We don't write in decimal--
I haven't had to write in
decimal expansion in quite
some time.
Anyways, now, of course,
not all rational numbers
can be written as a
finite decimal expansion.
For example, 1/3
you have to write
as 0.33333 and so on and so on.
So that's not necessarily
covered under the discussion
that I have right here.
But it will be
covered in what I'm
about to say for
the real numbers.
So we could cover 1/3.
And then we can also
cover every real number
if we allow infinite
decimal representations.
So I'll use the word decimal
expansions or decimal
representations
interchangeably there.
So let me make a definition.
And what I'm going to
state is about real numbers
between 0 and 1.
Of course, if you want to
talk about real numbers
bigger than 1, then you
just tack on 1 to the--
if you like, to the d0 place.
So the infinite part is
having to deal with what
comes after the decimal point.
So the let me make
the following.
So this is a
rigorous definition.
Let x in 0, 1 excluding 0.
And let d minus j
be in 0, 1 to 9.
for j, a natural number.
So we say x is--
so what does it
mean to say that x
is given by an infinite
decimal expansion
or given by an infinite
decimal representation?
We say x is represented
by the digits.
And we write x is equal to d
minus 1, d minus 2, d minus 3.
If-- so this is the
precise meaning of this.
If x is equal to the
supremum of the set--
so I take a finite
decimal expansion.
And then so I get a number
for each n, a natural number.
So the first one is just d
minus 1 10 to the minus 1.
And then for n equals 2, I
tack on next hundredths place,
and then the thousandths place.
And so I get a set
of real numbers.
If I take its
supremum and I get x,
then I say that x is represented
by these digits or that x--
or that this gives a
decimal representation of x.
So that you see this lines
up with what you know,
if I look at 0.250000, remember
this is now the sup of what?
Of a certain set.
So let me do first this guy.
So this is 2/10.
And then now, I add the
hundredths place plus 5/100,
and then 2/10 plus 5/100--
this is a set, remember--
plus 0/1000 over plus--
and at each next
guy, I'm supposed
to take this and
add on another 0.
So as a set, this is just a
set containing two elements,
namely 2/10 and 25/100.
And so this is
bigger than that guy.
So the supremum is
25/100, which equals 1/4.
OK, so all of that
to tell you that,
yes, this definition should--
or at least does
ring true with what
you were taught, that 1/4
is equal to 0.25, all right?
OK, so now that what we're done
with the triangle inequality,
I'm going to erase this.
And so this is the
last bit of discussion
about the elementary
properties of the real numbers.
Next, we'll be talking about
sequences of real numbers.
OK, so all right, so I
have this definition.
The fundamental theorem
about the real numbers
is that every real number, at
least in this setting between 0
and 1, can be represented
by a set of digits
or it has a decimal
representation.
And every decimal-- if you
like, every set of digits
corresponds to a
decimal representation
of a real number.
So let me state the
second thing I said first.
So for every set of digits d
minus j with each of these d
minus j's in 0 up
to 9, then there
exists a unique x in
closed interval 0, 1 such
that x is equal to d minus 1--
with this decimal
representation.
So you give me some
digits and I can
find a unique real
number that has
that decimal representation.
Now, before I state the
second part of the theorem,
this says that I
give you digits,
I get a unique real number.
Now, you ask about
the other direction.
If I have a real number, do
I get a unique set of digits?
And of course, that is
not true necessarily
because, for example, 1/2, this
is equal to 0.500 and so on.
But this is also equal
to 0.4999 and so on.
So yes, every set of digits
gives me a unique real number.
So if I gave you
these digits, they
would spit out 1/2 and only 1/2.
It wouldn't spit out 1/4.
But if you give
me a real number,
there does not necessarily
exist a unique set
of digits giving a decimal
expansion for that number.
So I can have two different
decimal expansions.
I have 0.5 and I have 0.4999.
I will always have at
least one, but it's not
necessarily unique.
But we can single
out one unique choice
by requiring that, in some
sense, if I were to truncate
it, then the decimal expansion
would be less than the number
I'm looking at and
wanting to expand.
So that's the second
part of this theorem,
is that for every x in
0, 1, now excluding 0,
there exists unique digits--
and as before, these
are in 0 up to 9--
such that x is--
such that these give a
decimal representation of x.
And so what singles out a
choice if we're ever coming up
against these two things?
And if I truncate the
decimal expansion--
so I'm not going to
write zeros after that.
I'm just going to truncate
it-- this always is less than x
and this is less than or equal
to plus 10 to the minus n.
All right, so this
inequality will always hold.
And in fact, so this
And in fact, x is
always bigger than
or equal to this
side, no matter what.
If x is given by a
decimal representation,
so we always have these two.
This is a less than
or equal to and this
is a less than or equal to.
But we single out
a unique choice
of decimal representation
by choosing
this to be a strict less than.
So then that forces us to
choose this guy over this guy.
So for theorem 2, this would say
that the unique representation
that satisfies this for
1/2 is given by 0.4999.
And for example, for
1 would be just 0.9999
because if I take this
representation and cut it off,
this is actually equal to
1/2 and not less than 1/2.
OK, so that was a lot of
discussion about the theorem.
But that was for a reason
because I'm not actually
going to prove this theorem.
It's not entirely
difficult. It just uses
the least upper bound
property of the real numbers.
But it's a little
clunky to write down.
And what I'd rather do
is just use this theorem
to prove my answer, the
answer to my question
up there, on whether R
is accountable or not.
In the textbook,
there is a proof
of this theorem,
which you can read.
OK, so we're actually
going to use this theorem
to prove the following
theorem due to Cantor.
So we just went from absolute
values, which maybe it was not
too shock and awe, now to this
theorem, which to me is shock
and awe, is the following,
that the interval 0, 1 is
uncountable.
All right, so maybe
you're asking yourself,
well, that's showing
this is uncountable.
And that's saying
R is uncountable.
So where do we go
from this to that?
Well, I'll let you
think about that.
But let's assume
this was uncountable
and R was countable.
So I'm just going to say
this, say why out loud.
If this was uncountable
and R was countable,
then since this is a subset
of R, that means this under
would be--
so let me just write.
Why does this imply--
And I'm going to give
you a fake proof,
but you can actually make
this completely rigorous--
fake proof in the
sense that I'm just
going to write symbols
that imply this.
So why is R uncountable
then if this is uncountable?
Well, the function that
takes an element in here
just into R, this is
clearly bijective.
so just the identity map from
0, 1 into R is an injective map.
So I clearly have that the
cardinality of this set
is less than or equal
to the cardinality of R.
In fact, maybe you
can think about it.
Maybe I'll put it
on the assignment.
But in fact, one can prove
they have the same cardinality.
But I have that.
And this is uncountable.
Therefore, its
cardinality is bigger
than the natural numbers.
So this should imply
that cardinality
of the natural numbers is less
than the cardinality of R.
In other words,
R is uncountable.
All right, so let's prove
this theorem due to Cantor.
Now, this other
theorem due to Cantor,
that the cardinality
of the power set
is bigger than the
cardinality of the set--
I mean, that was--
at least the proof,
the first time
I saw it, that was
some crazy shit.
And this is also going to be
some pretty crazy and clever
shit, too.
So this is what's referred to
as Cantor's diagonalization
argument or diagonal argument.
And it's the following.
So we're going to prove
this by contradiction.
So we're going to assume
that this is countable.
So it can't be finite.
There's infinitely many
of the elements in here.
So suppose that, in fact,
it has the cardinality
of the natural numbers.
And we're going to arrive
at a contradiction.
So then there exists
a function, which
I'm going to call x,
from natural numbers
into 0, 1, which is bijective.
Now, so let me label
this inequality star.
For each n, we write x of n.
So this is an element of 0, 1.
So this is bijective.
So every element in
0 gets mapped onto.
So we write x of n to be in
its decimal representation.
I have two indices now-- one
for the digit place and the one
for which--
excuse me.
At least I sheltered
you from that sneeze
by putting my hand
over the microphone.
Is the microphone still on?
Yeah.
OK, so for each n, we write
each x of n in its decimal
representation, satisfying star.
So each x in here can
be written uniquely
in a given decimal
representation satisfying
this inequality here.
And what we're
going to do is we're
going to come up with a real
number in the interval 0, 1
which x does not map to,
which therefore contradicts
the fact that x is surjective.
And bijective surjective
means that everything
has to get mapped onto.
That's the onto part.
Injective means it
maps different things
to different things.
So what's the idea of
finding this element that
doesn't get mapped onto?
So let me write down just a few
of these decimal expansions.
And I may not want
to do a fourth one.
And maybe I do.
So this is, again, discussion.
So I'm going to put
this in brackets,
meaning this is not
part of the proof,
but this is part of the
idea of what's going on.
And where's the diagonal part?
OK, so and this should go
off in this direction .
And the decimal expansion is
marked off in that direction.
And so somehow, this list, if
it kept going in that direction,
would have to contain every
real number between 0 and 1.
And so what's the idea to come
up with a real number between 0
and one that is not in
this list is we go down
the diagonal of the
decimal expansions
and we change each decimal to
something else than what it is.
And so therefore-- and
then I take my element y.
So remember, we're trying to
find a y not in this list.
And then I would take
y to be the real number
that I get by changing each
of these decimal digits.
So you can imagine if
y somehow popped up--
let's say it popped up, since
I don't want to write anymore,
as x4, then somehow
this number would
have to be the digit
for y, but I changed it.
And therefore, it's
not the digit of y.
So that's it in a nutshell.
If you didn't get
that, that's fine.
Let me now write
out the details.
So it's a little bit simpler
to imagine if, let's say,
all of these were 0's and 1's.
So instead of being base
10, now it's base 2.
And so instead of--
if the digit was the 0,
I've flipped it to 1.
So you can imagine
that if y did--
so and then I form y
by flipping the digits.
So if this was 0, 0, 1, 1, then
y would start off 1, 1, 0, 0.
And therefore, if y appeared,
say, fourth in line,
it would have to be 1
and 0 in the same spot
just by how I've constructed
y by flipping it.
And therefore, y
can't be in that list.
And therefore, this map
cannot be surjective,
which is our contradiction.
So let me make
this more precise.
Let ej-- this is going to be 1.
If the j-th digit
of the j-th x of j
does not equal 1;
2, if the j-th digit
of the j-th guy in that list,
or x of j, does equal 1.
By part 1 of the theorem,
previous theorem,
there exists the unique
y in 0, 1 without 0--
why?
Because some of these
digits are non-zero.
It's always either 1 or 2--
such that y is equal to e
minus 1, e minus 2, and so on.
So moreover, since all of
these digits are either 1 or 2,
they are certainly non-zero.
So y is given by a decimal
expansion where all
of these things are non-zero.
So that means that for
all n, a natural number,
if I take a finite decimal
expansion-- so I cut this
off at e to the minus n--
since e to the e minus n
plus 1 is either 1 or 2,
that's going to be positive.
So that's less than y.
And this is always
the case, that this
is less than or equal to.
So because all these
digits are positive,
if I cut it off,
if I truncate it,
then that number is
going to be less than y
because I'm missing stuff
out in the millionths place
or whatever each
time for each n.
And therefore, this
decimal expansion
is the unique decimal
representation
from part 2 of the
theorem that I stated.
Every element in 0, 1 has
a unique representation,
satisfying that inequality.
Because all of these digits
are positive, this, in fact,
is a unique representation
of this element
y, which I've constructed by
flipping digits from this map.
Now, since x is
surjective, there
exists an n, natural number--
this n has nothing
to do with that n.
Maybe I'll use a
different letter, m--
such that y equals x of m.
Then let's say I look
at e to the minus m.
So then this says
that the m-th digit,
which should be giving me e
to the minus m because this is
equal to --
this, remember, is equal to
1 if dm 2 if dm equals 1.
In particular, this
does not equal dm.
So I have proven that this
number does not equal itself.
All right, I can never if--
I can never have
this number, whatever
it is, equal to this thing
because I'm always changing it.
If this thing is 1,
then this number is 2.
If this number is not 1,
then this number is 1.
And therefore, it's
not equal to that.
And this is a contradiction.
Thus, it shows that
this set is uncountable.
So I hope I explained
that well enough.
You can also look in the
textbook for an explanation
as well.
And of course, you can
ask me in office hours
for more explanation.
Let me fuel up real quick.
OK, now, we're moving
onto a new chapter.
We're going to get to--
now, we're going to get
to the analysis part.
So analysis as I've said
before, is the study of limits.
Real analysis is the
study of limits that
has to deal with real numbers.
So let's get to our
first notion of a limit.
And that is the limit of a
sequence of real numbers.
So now, we're moving onto
sequences and series.
So what is the
precise definition
of a sequence of real numbers?
A sequence of real
numbers is precisely
a function x from
the natural numbers
into R, just a function.
It doesn't have to be bijective,
surjective, injective,
anything.
It's just a function from
the natural numbers to R.
So that's precisely what a
sequence of real numbers is.
Now, we typically don't think
of a sequence as a function.
In fact, we don't even
use that notation.
We denote x of n by x
sub n and the associated
sequence by this curly brackets,
n equals 1 to infinity.
Or we might not even write the
n equals 1 to infinity part
or just start listing them.
All right, so let me
quickly say that although--
so again, a sequence,
unambiguously defined,
is a function from the
natural numbers to real.
So don't confuse
this with a set.
A sequence is not a set.
So think of a sequence,
even though again it's
defined as a function, as
just an infinite listing
of elements of R--
one element, the first
element, the second element,
the third element, and so on.
And they don't have
to be different.
So for example, 1, 1, 1, 1, that
is a perfectly good sequence.
In terms of what
is the function,
this is x of n
equals 1 for all n.
But again, I will not
think of really a sequence
as a function.
Just as we never thought about
functions as subsets of--
as certain subsets of the
Cartesian product of two sets,
you should really think of these
as just a list of real numbers.
And when we refer to
them, we'll either
write them like that
or with curly brackets
around an expression
for x sub n.
So for example, if I
were to write this,
this means this is the sequence
given by 1, 1/2, 1/3, 1/4, 1/5,
and so on.
OK.
So here's another definition.
So a sequence is bounded
if, in some sense,
it doesn't run off to
arbitrarily large values.
So sequence x sub n is
bounded if there exists
some real number b
bigger than or equal
to 0 such that for all n
in the natural numbers xn
is less than or equal
to b in absolute value.
So again, for example, if
we take a look back at both
of those two sequences--
1, 1, 1, and the
sequence 1 over n--
these are bounded.
Why?
Because every element in this--
I shouldn't say element, but
every entry in this sequence
is equal to 1.
So it's bounded by 1.
And every entry in this sequence
is less than or equal to 1.
So it's bounded by
1 in absolute value.
It's also positive.
So they're both bounded.
Another example is the
sequence minus 1 to the n.
So I'll write equals,
although this shouldn't-- this
doesn't mean anything.
I'm just going to write it--
write it-- or start listing
the entries-- minus 1,
1, minus 1, 1, minus 1, 1.
This is also bounded because
the absolute value of minus 1
to the n is 1.
So that's bounded
by 1 for all n.
So what's a non-example?
The sequence n-- in
other words, this
is the sequence 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, and so on.
Now, precisely why is it un--
so I should say this is bounded.
And otherwise, I'll refer to x
sub n as unbounded, unbounded.
So why is it unbounded?
Because the entries are getting
larger and larger in size.
But if I were to ask
you to prove this,
you would have to show--
and this is also a
good first exercise--
what does it mean
to be unbounded.
So I said this at one
point, that if you
come across a reasonably
interesting definition,
you should look up or try
to come up with examples.
And typically, when you
do come up with examples,
you should come up
with non-examples.
And what that requires you to
do is negate the definition.
What does it mean for
something to not be that?
So even though I'm saying
that if it's not bounded
I call it unbounded,
I haven't actually
written a mathematical
statement to this effect
on what this means.
So let me make this
right here as a remark.
So a sequence is
unbounded, so if it doesn't
satisfy that definition.
So we need to negate
this definition.
The definition says
this is bounded
if there exists a b bigger
than or equal to 0 such
that this holds for all n.
Now, when I negate a there
exists, that becomes a for all.
And when I negate a for all,
that becomes a there exists.
And then I negate
this condition.
So the sequence is unbounded
if for all b bigger than
or equal to 0 there exists
a natural number in n
such that xn in absolute
value is bigger than b.
Now, using this-- so
this is-- if you like,
you can take that as
a second definition.
Or it's not really a definition,
since it's just the negation
of the first definition.
Why is this set unbounded?
Because of the
Archimedean property.
So now, I'm giving you a
little short proof on why
this sequence is unbounded.
Let b be bigger
than or equal to 0.
By the Archimedean
property, there
exists a natural number
n such that n is bigger
than b, which is
exactly what we wanted
to prove because, in this case,
x sub n is n, is unbounded.
OK, now, what does
it mean for us
to have a limit of a sequence?
What does a limit
of a sequence mean?
What does it mean
for a real number
to be the limit of a sequence?
What does it mean for a sequence
to converge to something?
So the sequence x sub n
converges to a real number
x in R if the following
condition is satisfied--
if for every epsilon positive,
there exists a natural number
capital M such that
for all n bigger
than or equal to capital M
xn minus x absolute value
is less than epsilon.
Now, remember the
absolute value is
meant to be something
like a distance.
So what does this statement say?
This says if I give you a little
bit of tolerance, epsilon,
and you go far enough
out in the sequence,
then the distance between that
entry in the sequence and x
are very close to each other.
Let me finish stating the
rest of this definition
and we'll do a little
more discussion.
If a sequence converges,
we say it's convergent.
Otherwise, we say
it's divergent.
So all right, let me draw--
let me draw a little picture
of what this is meant to be.
So the real numbers,
it was this--
I mean, it is this
unique ordered field
with the least upper
bound property.
But when you think
about the real numbers,
think of it as you've
always thought about it,
as just the real number line.
So what does this
definition mean?
It means that a sequence
converges to some
x if for every epsilon
I can do the following.
If I look at--
if I give you an epsilon and you
go on either side of x epsilon
amount, then you should be
able to find a capital M so
that if you look at entries
in your sequence x sub n for n
bigger than or equal to
M they're in this guy.
So then I should have x sub
M there, x sub M plus 1,
x sub M plus 2.
And in general, x sub
n should be in there,
as long as n is bigger
than or equal to M.
So I should be able to do
this for every epsilon.
So for any amount of
tolerance epsilon,
you should be able to go far
enough out in the sequence
that all entries
in that sequence
are within this tolerance of x.
I mean, although this is a
picture of what the definition
means, how should you--
I mean, you've probably
gotten plenty of experience
with sequences when you
were doing calculus.
But what does this mean loosely?
It means if I look close to x,
some little interval containing
x, then all of the sequence, all
of the elements of the sequence
should be eventually in this--
in this little interval.
Or another way to
think about it is
that as I go on in the sequence,
the entries are getting closer
and closer and closer to
x Now, the way one makes
these last two intuitive
statements precise
is via this definition.
The closer and closer
part is encapsulated
in this for all epsilon part.
And eventually getting closer
and closer means for all n
bigger than or
equal to capital M.
As long as I go far enough
out in the sequence,
they're getting close to x.
So I hope that's pretty clear.
All right, so again,
we have a definition.
And it's reasonably interesting.
So we should do examples,
and then also negate it.
But before I do
either of those, I
do want to just prove
a very simple fact
about convergent
sequences, namely
that if I have a sequence
which converges to x, then x
is the only thing that
sequence can converge to.
I cannot have a convergent
sequence which converges to two
different things.
Like I said, if you
go by this intuition
that eventually the
x sub n's are getting
closer and closer and
closer to x, well,
then there's no way they
can be also getting closer
to something other than x.
So I just want to
prove that real quick.
And then we'll do examples and
a negation of this definition.
So the following theorem--
and so I'm going to state
first the theorem that
has nothing to do
with sequences,
but is a nice way if you want
to show two things are equal.
You can show they're
smaller than anything.
So the first theorem
that I'm going to state
is if x and y are in R and
all epsilon positive x minus y
is less than epsilon,
then x equals y.
This is not a
surprising statement.
If I have x and y and
the distance between them
is arbitrarily small, then
they have to be the same thing.
So what's the proof?
Suppose xy is in R. And for
all epsilon positive, x minus y
is less than epsilon.
So now, I want to
prove x equals y.
So let's assume that this
does not hold and arrive
at a contradiction.
So this is a short
proof by contradiction.
Suppose x does not equal y.
Then remember we proved that
the absolute value of something
is 0 if and only if
that thing is equal to 0
and it's always non-negative.
So x not equal to y means the
absolute value of x minus y
is less than-- is bigger than 0.
Then by this
assumption, for epsilon
equal to x minus
y over 2, I get--
which implies if I just
subtract that over, x minus y
is less than 0.
So 1/2 is less than 0 or--
and that's a very
false statement.
We've already proven that
the absolute value is always
non-negative.
So if I have two real
numbers that are arbitrarily
close to each other, then
they have to be the same.
I'm going to use this
theorem to prove that--
I don't know why
I put a 1 there--
why limits-- and I have not
said that's what we call x--
but why a convergent sequence
can only converge to one thing.
So here is the statement
of the second theorem.
If x sub n is a sequence
and it converges
to x and it also converges
to y, then x equals y.
So a convergent sequence can
only converge to one thing.
And again, like I said,
there should be clear
because what's happening is if
I have two things that are not
equal and x sub
n converges to x,
that means as long as I go far
enough out in the sequence,
they're supposed to be here in
this small interval around x.
Well, if they're supposed
to be converging to y,
if I go far enough
out, they're also
supposed to be over here as
long as I go far enough out.
But you can't be in two
places at once ever.
And so that's why
x must equal y.
Although, I suppose
that now we're
doing all the classes
online, some are recorded.
So you can be two places at
once, but at least not here.
OK, so we're going
to use this theorem
to prove this statement.
Suppose-- converges to x and y.
And I want to verify that
for all epsilon positive
the absolute value of
x minus y is less than
or equal to epsilon.
Now, remember if I'm proving
something for all epsilon,
I have to-- that means I do
it for arbitrary epsilon.
You get points just for setting
let epsilon be positive.
OK, now, I want to show the
absolute value of x minus y
is less than or
equal to epsilon.
And we're basically going to
do the argument that I just
erased.
So since x sub n
converges to x, that
implies that there exists a
natural number M1 such that
for all n bigger
than or equal to M1,
x sub n minus x is less
than epsilon over 2.
Why the epsilon over 2?
You'll see, magic happens.
And since x sub
n converges to y,
thus this implies that there
exists an M2 natural number
such that for all n bigger
than or equal to M2--
so again, this is
the part that says
as long as I go far enough out
s sub n has to be close to x.
Now, this is the
part that says as
long as I go far enough out x
sub n has to be close to y--
so that for all n bigger than
or equal to M2 x sub n minus y
is less than epsilon over 2.
Then since the sum M1 plus--
these are both natural numbers.
This is bigger than
or equal to M1 and M2.
This implies-- now, I'm going
to use these two inequalities
and the triangle inequality.
Then if I look at the
absolute value of x minus y,
this is equal to
the absolute value
of x minus x sub n
plus x sub n minus--
so let me-- not x sub n, but
x sub M1 plus M2 plus x sub M1
plus M2.
Now, by the triangle
inequality, this
is less than or equal to x
M2 plus M1 plus M2 minus y.
Now, this is less
than epsilon over 2
because M1 plus M2 is
bigger than or equal to M1.
And for the same reason,
since plus M1 plus M2
is bigger than or equal to
M2, this is less than epsilon
over 2.
Ah, now you see why I
divided both of those
by 2 because when I add
them up, I get epsilon.
So I've shown that for
every epsilon positive,
the absolute value of x
minus y is less than epsilon.
And therefore, by the theorem
that I proved a minute ago,
x equals y.
Why did I state that theorem?
Because I want to use notation.
And I want this notation
to be already apparent
that it's consistent.
And I'm going to
use terminology.
So I mean, this is not
really a new definition.
It's just some terminology.
We call x the limit
of the sequence.
Now, the fact that I've shown
only that there's only one
guy that a sequence
can converge to
is why I get to use
the word "the--"
so not we call x a
limit of x sub n.
It's the limit because there's
only one, if one exists--
and write x equals limit as n
goes to infinity of x sub n.
OK, so let's pause on negating
the definition of what
it means for a sequence
to be convergent.
And let's do a
couple of examples
of convergent sequences,
proving that they
are convergent sequences
and computing what they--
and at least proving
that these sequences
do converge to the limit
that I'm telling you.
So for example, let's look
at the constant sequence
x sub n equals 1 for all N. So
that's the sequence 1, 1, 1,
and so on.
Then I'm just going to
write 1, not x sub n.
The limit as n goes to
infinity of 1 equals 1.
This proof is not
very enlightening,
but I'll show you how it goes.
So you're supposed to show--
what does this mean?
This means for every
epsilon positive,
there exist a natural
number capital M such
that if I'm bigger than
capital M, this minus the limit
should be less than epsilon.
So let epsilon be positive.
I have to now come
up with a capital M
so that x sub n minus
x is less than epsilon
whenever little n is bigger
than or equal to capital M.
So I'm going to choose
capital M to be 1.
I can do that for this sequence.
Then if n is bigger
than or equal to M
and I look at the n-th
entry in the sequence,
well, this is just
1 minus 1 equals 0.
And that's less than epsilon.
So not very enlightening
because capital M equals 1
is good enough.
So let's do something
a little more.
So how about the limit as
n goes to infinity of 1
over n equals 0?
So let's do a proof of this.
Again, I'm supposed to be
proving this epsilon statement
in the definition in order to
be able to state this, which
is for every epsilon statement.
So I start the proof off
with let epsilon be positive.
Now, I have to find--
I have to tell you how to
choose capital M to ensure
that little n bigger than
or equal to capital M
implies x sub n minus 0, in
this case, is less than epsilon.
So I will say choose capital
M natural number such
that m is bigger
than 1 over epsilon.
In fact, I'm not going
to write it that way.
I'm going to write it this way--
1 over M is less than epsilon.
And Why Can I do this?
Why can I find such a natural
number that satisfies this?
And you can't just insert
statements into your proof--
choose capital M to satisfy
the unicorn property--
and not clarify
why you can choose
such a natural number that
satisfies the unicorn property.
I can do this by the
Archimedean property.
This is equivalently
stating that I
can find a natural
number M so that n
is bigger than 1
over epsilon, what
I had written there originally.
So let me write it this way--
such an M exists by the
Archimedean property
of the natural numbers.
I'll say that a few
times if I have to
or to clarify why certain
natural numbers satisfying
certain properties exist.
And then at one
point, I'll just stop
because it should be clear
that I've done it enough times
you know how or why
something does exist.
OK, so I choose a natural
number and a natural number
M so that I have this.
Now, I need to show you
that this number works.
So let n be bigger
than capital M. Then
if I look at x sub n minus my
proposed limit, which is 0--
so I look at 1 minus n 0--
this is equal to just 1 over n.
Since little n is bigger
than or equal to capital M,
this is less than or
equal to capital M, which
is less than epsilon.
And therefore, I've proven
what I wanted to prove.
So how do these--
if I just give you a sequence
and I ask you to prove that--
so this is some discussion.
How do you come up
with these proofs?
How should the proof
typically look?
If I want to prove--
equals L or x, what's the
proof of that look like?
It should always-- so the
proof should be let epsilon
be positive.
And then maybe you need
to do some explaining.
And then you'll say choose
M so that something.
And that such an
M exists probably
will be explained there
or in the same sentence.
And then the next
part of the proof
should be showing that
this capital M works.
So then if n is bigger
than or equal to capital M,
then you should
show that it works
by looking at x sub
n minus x and doing
a calculation or inequalities
and arriving at this being less
than epsilon, which is what
you're wanting to prove.
You're wanting, in the end, to
verify this definition, which
says for every epsilon,
you can find a capital M
so that I get this.
So in a proof, you
are carrying that out.
You're saying for
epsilon positive,
I choose M so that this happens.
Now, how do you--
how do you come up
with such a capital M?
So again, this is
just discussion.
And maybe we won't get
to any more examples.
I'll just finish
this discussion,
and then we'll call it a day.
How do you come up
with such a capital M?
How did I come up with M?
Why did I choose M in this way?
In the end, you
can see it here, is
that I chose it because
if I fiddle around
with the thing I want to bound,
I ended up with 1 over n, which
I can control and make
it smaller than epsilon.
So typically, how do
you find capital M?
So this is a discussion, I
guess, within a discussion.
Typically, you'll take x sub n
minus x, your proposed limit.
Maybe I give you a
sequence explicitly.
Or maybe it's a expression
involving some other sequences.
And you fiddle around with it.
Maybe you write it differently,
or add and subtract something,
or multiply it by
1 in a fancy way.
And you'll get some
expression typically
involving something involving n.
And as long as this expression
involving n is simple enough,
then you choose capital
M so that this thing
is less than epsilon.
Now, simple enough,
for example, 1 over n,
I can choose capital M so
that this is less than epsilon
by the Archimedean property.
If, for example-- and
that's basically 1 over n,
or 5 over n, or
something like that,
that exhausts all the
simplest ones for now.
But if, for example,
you ended up with 1
over n squared
minus 3n plus 100,
I would not say this is a
simple enough expression
to be able to say choose
capital M so that this is less
than epsilon without more
explanation than what I just
gave here.
And we'll do some more
examples next time
to flesh this out
a little bit more.
All right, so we'll stop there.